Um, I've been talking about
what makes people a champion.
Like I talked to Tony Romo right
after the super bowl about, you know,
you came from eastern Illinois University.
It's like got what,
nine students or something and he's a
little bit of university and he turns out
to be quarterback if
America's team for 14 years,
set all kinds of records and then goes
to the booth and becomes a number one
color analyst in television. I
mean, champion, champion, champion.
Why you, what is it, what
do you attribute that to?
I like asking those questions
and hearing people talk.
What do you say to young people
about that? What made you a champion?
Are you going to let your
kids play football with all
this CTE and stuff? What,
what do you say? I like having
those kinds of conversations.
Did the same thing with Shaq and
Charles Barkley and different people.
What did he say about what makes
you a champion, you know, for him?
Um,
he said that he has this,
um,
he says he didn't,
he wasn't the kind of swagger sort of
person that, you know, came in Cocky,
like he was gonna own the
field and own the game.
But inside he said he had this
absolute drive that if he didn't win,
he couldn't live with it.
It's like if somebody thought
like he played the game,
somebody beat them,
beat him.
That just the idea that that person
went home thinking that they were better
than him,
that they could beat him,
that he just couldn't eat,
sleep.
Think until he got back and owned it
again and got back to it. He said he just,
is this, this drive to
win. And so he would,
I mean he said he would be out at one
o'clock in the morning and the dome
throwing a pass that that
route got intercepted.
He got jumped on that route and you'd be
trying to figure out why on Thursday in
practice,
he saw what he needed to see,
why didn't we see it on Sunday and
he would analyze, analyze, analyze,
until he could get there, until he
could do it, until he could win it.
He just had this drive to win
that super unhealthy obsession.
They all share that Michael
Jordan had that. I mean,
we've talked about that
several times on the podcast.
So many people that are extreme winners,
they're psychotic and their
obsession with winning. Yeah.
That's all they want to do. And
if they lose, they, they, they,
it's almost in softball.
They almost can't deal with it.
Yeah. And that, I don't know
that necessarily a bad thing,
but the difference between winners and
losers as winners do things losers do not
want to do. Yeah. They, they will
get up in the middle of the night.
They will do this, they will do that.
They feel it more, they just do things.
Losers don't want to do and pay a
price. Losers just don't to pay. Yeah.
And lose your, it's just not worth it
and every winner has been loser. Oh,
well that's what made him a winter.
Yeah. If all you ever do, if it's,
if you go through, life is in
a success only journey. God,
how boring would that be me?
You think it would be great,
but it's like eating ice cream
every meal about the fourth meal,
you're going to be thinking, God,
let's kill something and eat it.